youtube what's good uh today i want to
talk about content strategy this is
something i've been
blasting on for 15 years uh and it's
something that's evolved
quite a bit so i wanted to make this
video to break it down the evolution the
ebb and flow
how things have changed update it
contextualize it
and bring you the most value as i
download my thoughts
on content strategy the number one thing
you should do more than anything
is use this interview as the case study
to become
a better micro storyteller to under to
awareness against this let me explain
you probably don't have a tumblr
okay no no here's and by the way i don't
do it super well either even though i
was in a basketball let's stick here
because i want to be detailed
you should start one you should have i
love marketing
tumblr account because there's plenty of
14 to 21 year old huck
you know hipsters that love that love
tumblr right that have never heard of
you me or anybody else because they're
they're in the streets they're cool but
they want to be entrepreneurs
you take one moment from here where
you're holding up the wallet or where
i'm being silly
and you make it an animated gif you know
what an animated gif is right yeah the
looping over
you put an animated gif on tumblr with
one of the quotes from you or me
from this interview and then that quote
links back to the itunes downloaded this
you have nobody on your tumblr account
just like anybody would when they start
right but you take this interview and
you link your tumblr
you blast out an email and say we're now
on tumblr and you get ten eleven fifty
it's un you know how it works you start
at zero you build you should do that you
should make an
infographic that's female centric things
that you believe the female psychology
would have gotten out of this
and make an infographic and start your
pinterest board of infographics from
your interviews
you get one influential pinterest person
to repin it
and you could have 10 15 100 000 people
get new awareness about your show
and pinterest is a dream it clicks out
to wherever you want
so your infographic that you made from
this seven fun things gary said
you know what infographics look like
yeah and that links out to
the podcast download i mean this is the
future man micro content as a gateway
drug
to awareness to your bigger thing so
put out micro pieces of content i'm a
big believer and i look i think that i'm
hitting
a golden era in my content production
live streaming
my snapchat stories game is up my
instagram game is up
my twitter's still on point my facebook
fan page content is up
linkedin is is stronger than it was
before pinterest we're still lagging we
need to really get our pinterest game
out right
it'll happen for wine library i think i
know but we're talking about me now
steve not my library
uh you know pinterest needs to get up a
little bit but you need to put out micro
contents the reason i wrote jab jab jab
right hook
is to get you to put out different
little pieces of content
that still thematically ladder back up
to what you're doing on your website
that are contextual for the platform big
ed don't get lazy on me
your big ed go out there and put out
content across
the board and and don't just make it
remember the jabs need to be jabs don't
just make the content where you're like
my biggest idea ever is dot dot dot
go to my website your website will get
traffic as a byproduct and you
are able to throw right hooks in those
social platforms but put out jobs of
value
to the audience where they actually
spend their time big ed
they love you and they they want to go
to your website but they'd rather
more than being on your website be in
all these other places and it's up to
you to be there
and use that as a gateway drug to get
them back well look i mean
you should you should be putting out
content on a very regular basis
you should start a pillar show whether
it's i mean vlogging i think is very
fascinating
you know you should be doing instagram
stories and snapchat stories at scale
you should be putting out seven to 25
pieces of content on both those
platforms
a day and let me explain how
don't go fancy document
versus create when you when you make you
like that right
it's a big it's a big shift when i say 7
to 25 you say my god how do i produce 7
to 25
meaningful things that will have me
respected versus
document see that's
that's that's always the thing is like
meaningful that will get me respected i
feel like
anybody can put up [ __ ] you know i don't
want to put out [ __ ]
but [ __ ] is subjective my man
and i got good news for you you're fully
in control
yeah yeah people was like gary put
like i'm in control how many things i
say no they send me quotes to put out on
instagram nope
i'm in control
who makes the final call in like
productions the producer the director i
don't know whoever
who's the final person great you're the
producer my man
yeah right i don't know you you take a
selfie with a nice skyline and
yeah but you got to put out stuff and
you
and you got to fabricate it like when
you're like i still can't believe how
many people that live in new york don't
use new york people
if i were you and i had an hour right
now going to [ __ ] park right now
right now like i don't know like go back
to your basketball route stand outside
the garden right there and be like what
do you think about the knicks upcoming
season
yeah interview four people one person
gets into a thoughtful conversation
he was the former ball boy in 1957 it's
a nice story and boom
you see where i'm going document over
create how many of you heard that from
me document over create
great so that took me a long time to get
to
maybe like seven years but it was the
thing that really unlocked it for a lot
of people just for a lot of you my point
on
on creating content is instead of trying
to think what you make
just document everything you're doing if
you act do you know the two or three of
you if you just documented
the journey of figuring this out that
people would watch your video on youtube
every day
of you trying to figure out the school
system and that in itself was what would
build your business
it's a story it's the journey of an
entrepreneur
the legacy that i'm creating with
dailyvee [ __ ]
you know cool that's gonna be when
there's 10 years worth of my every day
especially if i pull off very big things
i would love you know how fun it would
be to watch
the three years before drake became
famous everything he did
so what was the inspiration to start
this and to release must be a lot of
work
you know it's a lot more it's it's
actually not a lot of work it's actually
been an incredibly
smart strategy to be honest you know i
live my life
somebody documents it they post produce
i am not egotistical or
or too romantic and so i don't really
get involved in post-production
i mean it literally i don't even know i
mean it doesn't take a lot of work at
all
which is scary compared to the impact it
has it creates a
consistent show which works it also
feeds
all my written audio and other micro
video content
i mean the fact that i can put out a
clip uh on instagram a couple days ago
that gets a million
organic views and have that branding in
that 20
you know 20 to 35 demo that i'm so
desperate to have
and the fact that was just one moment of
me being at wine library on a saturday
giving a 13 year old kid some advice
that we post edited and chopped up in
post-production on my media team
internally that's incredible like i'm
i'm i think i've figured it out macro
content at scale
which then creates micro content at
scale
all of which doesn't do anything to me
other than
force me to actually live my life i'm
not doing anything today for dailyvee
i'm living life and so it's a very
interesting thing that i'm doing because
i'm confusing a lot of people
i've created an incredible perception
that i spend all my time on my personal
brand
in a world where i spend none of my time
on my personal brand
you talked a little bit about quality
being subjective
and in a lot of ways that that comes to
play with this idea
uh i i want to push back a little bit on
that yeah because i i mean at least from
my own
experience it's been producing one high
quality video
every single week and that's like
eventually what it became
in the beginning it was podcasting i'm
doing eight teasers for every single
podcast i'm putting them on social i'm
sharing them with the people that
were on my show and it became so much
work
when i was seeing a massive return on
these short edited videos that i was
making
eight to ten minute videos on youtube
and then it
became for me how can i make one amazing
video
every week versus five decent videos
that's what worked for you
yeah and for steven spielberg it's one
movie
you know a year yours is doing way too
much volume for him
right and for me it's not even close to
enough volume
because i think there's 47 meaningful
pieces of content potentially in this 40
minutes we spent together
i think that's right i think that goes
back to self-awareness and back to the
theme
that's i think evolving here which is
this is very contextual
you know um i think that's right for you
and by the way i think the debate for
you is
if you know how much micro content does
come out of
this 40 minutes it used to be a lot more
yeah and i mean because it was just for
me here's the question
and if you hire somebody for 40 000 a
year who's great at it
in post-production contextual to social
will it be much more and will that lead
to much more awareness to the top
of the macro piece of content that
you're passionate about yeah and then it
becomes what are your ambitions do you
want to make that an
investment so i really don't think
there's a right or wrong
i think that what i'm passionate about
is oh my god
there's a permission for an enormous
amount of content
and for you this has been the way it
played out but for some people
a single piece of micro content on
instagram became the piece
that brought them awareness to their
long-form youtube video
my number one thesis is producing
content at scale right now it is
such an opportunity i i couldn't you
know i'm gonna beat this horse until not
only is it dead
but it's buried and i throw a bomb on it
you know
this is this is the for everybody in
here
who's nowhere close or not at where they
want to be
it is absolutely the most cost effective
way
to start the process to whatever you
want it is about producing content
producing content at scale for as many
platforms as possible
so many people in this room could have
all the things that they wanted to
happen
on youtube and on instagram for the last
three and a half years and has not
happened
actually happen if they get serious
about tick tock for the next six months
what is amazing about the volume model
is
the notion of marketing for the sake of
better marketing
so what happens after you post those 78
is you start getting
quant and qual feedback
and what you do with that feedback is
you make the next decision
which is are you going to write more
about that or has there been such a huge
reaction
to people's response on
what 5g actually means to their
day-to-day
not just faster and better battery but
how our entire world changes when you
create that speed
of information how that actually makes
autonomous cars real how that actually
allows a doctor in peru
to perform a surgery on somebody in new
york how that actually actually actually
does
when you see the response now all of a
sudden you say you know what
that little three sentences we said
about did you know
when 5g is in your life this happens got
such a big response
why don't we now have our
graphic designer make an infographic
real quick around five things you don't
know about 5g
and let's post that at 3 37 p.m today
and then when that goes well then you
decide why don't make a quick little
video on our iphone talking
to lars in r d he knows a lot about this
[ __ ]
let's go over to him large says it and
then you just post it not
with what's quality with green screen
and lighting
i mean i was powdered before i came out
here right now
[Laughter]
that to me is not the variable of
success of this talk
that was not going to be the variable
that made this go well or not
it was what i was going to say youtube
watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls more
content more engagement more surprise
and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you